[Music]
what's going on guys this is Rob and
today on our vs. series we're going to
focus on a battle that is often the
subject of debate among comic book fans
doomsday versus the Hulk and I've
actually done a video on this battle
years ago on my channel when we did
doomsday versus world breaker Hulk so
for this video we're gonna shift things
up and we're gonna focus on another
incarnation of the Incredible Hulk the
version we see in the heart of the
monster storyline at the end of Greg
packs run with the character so the
first thing we need to do in determining
a winner is to explain how this version
of the Hulk differs from other versions
that we've seen so of course the
Incredible Hulk debuted in 1962 in the
Incredible Hulk number 1 and was created
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby now as most
of you are probably familiar with the
Hulk was a scientist named Bruce Banner
that was exposed to gamma radiation and
became a super-strong gray skin monster
every night of course over the years
there have been a lot of changes to the
hoax character most notably that he's
usually depicted as green a set of gray
the idea that the Hulk can only come out
at night was largely dropped at least
until al Huey's run on the immortal Hulk
and the Hulk continued to grow stronger
now during gray patch run with the Hulk
he devised a way to remove hope from the
landscape while the Marvel Civil War was
going on pretty much due to the fact
that whichever side the Hulk would
choose would basically have been
guaranteed victory
so what regpack did is he created a
storyline where some of the Earth's
heroes called the Illuminati decided
that the Hulk was too big of a threat to
remain on the planet they loaded him
into a rocket and launched him into
space which was kind of a really
terrible thing to do thinking that is
headed for an uninhabited planet
ultimately the idea was the Incredible
Hulk would be able to live out the rest
of his days peacefully long story short
he actually lands on the planet of Sekar
ruled by a cruel despot named the Red
King and Hulk overthrows the Red King
marries a woman named Kiara and the two
learned that they're having a child and
the ship that brought into the planet
ends up blowing up killing his wife and
his unborn child as well predictably
this pisses the Hulk off to no end and
he ends up going back to earth to get
his revenge on those that he thinks are
responsible and since this is the
angriest that we had seen The Incredible
Hulk up to that point and because the
Incredible Hulk gets stronger as he gets
angrier the version of the hope that we
saw after he returns to Earth commonly
referred to as world breaker Hulk was as
strong as that we'd ever seen that isn't
the events of the heart of the monsters
storyline so during that story a named
scientist transforms a Fountain of Youth
used by the villain Tyrannis into a
wishing well the grants wishes to those
who come into contact with its waters
one of the Hulk's old rivals armed
Shedden tortures his friend Rick Jones
and his cousin Jennifer Walters angering
him to the point that he reverts back
into the world record form
eventually the Hulk makes a wish and
he's transported to the Dark Dimension
ruled by his former lover Umar where
he's basically freed of having to
restrain himself so as not to hurt any
innocence since they're basically aren't
any in the Dark Dimension The Hulk
himself says explicitly that during the
events of world war hulk he was still
holding back and now he doesn't have to
do that meaning that this version The
Incredible Hulk
is even stronger than world breaker this
is really significant because as we
learned from dr. Strange's remarks the
Hulk was capable of destroying the
entire planet when he was in his world
record form and we can consider Doctor
Strange a reliable witness here because
he was present during the World War Hulk
storyline and got his butt kicked by
world breaker Hulk even while possessed
by a crazy powerful demon named song now
as far as what powers the Hulk has of
course
his most notable power is his strength
which increases as he gets angrier and
has no known upper limit in addition to
strength the Hulk is also insanely
durable and has an incredibly efficient
healing factor allowing him to heal for
pretty much any damage he takes and he's
able to produce powerful blasts of gamma
radiation now I'm not going to go into
all the world breaker holds feats even
though we know heart of the monster Hulk
could do them all because this isn't a
world breaker Hulk's video and I went
over the big ones when we covered world
breaker Hulk instead I'm just going to
highlight one feat which in and of
itself shows us how ridiculously
powerful the Hulk is in that form this
particular feat is that the Incredible
Hulk fights and defeats Fin Fang Foom
after he ingests dozens of nuclear
warheads and viewing him with millions
of megatons of nuclear energy Foom is
definitely capable of destroying a
planet in this form but is defeated by
the Hulk along with the red she-hulk
pretty easily now on the other side of
this battle we have doomsday now
doomsday was created by Dan Jergens with
input from several other creators and
made his first appearance and Superman
the Man of Steel number 18 and 1992
doomsday was created for the express
purpose of being someone that could
physically rival Superman Doomsday's
origin lies and Superman's home planet
of Krypton
where he was genetically engineered to
be a being desiring only to destroy all
in his path when he reaches earth he
battles Superman and famously kills him
in the death of Superman's storyline now
the reason doomsday makes such a fitting
opponent for the Hulk is that he and
Hulk have an extremely similar power set
like the Hulk
doomsday possesses super-strength the
level of which has varied throughout the
years depending on who's riding him but
he's defeated not only Superman but dark
side as well so we know that in terms of
physical strength he's near the top of
the spectrum in the DC Universe also
like the Hulk doomsday possesses
superhuman stamina and his armored hide
provides him an insane level of
durability and during the hunter prey
storyline he was able to survive
Darkseid's Omega beams Superman's heat
vision and a force equivalent to a
million nuclear blast
now doomsday also has a regenerative
healing factor that allows him to heal
from whatever damage he takes now
doomsday is unique in that in the event
that he's killed he involuntarily
resurrects himself and is immune to
whatever it was that causes previous
death so for instance if he drowned once
the next time he came back he couldn't
be killed by drowning
another unique attribute doomsday has is
that he can rapidly evolve to exploit
the weakness of his opponents he's given
himself the ability of flight in battle
and he's given himself the ability to
breathe fire when he was fighting
Martian Manhunter
who's afraid of fire so he can
constantly add to his own repertoire of
powers as the battle dictates to exploit
any weakness of his opponent so the
ultimate question is who wins in this
battle well how I see this playing out
is really there the two of these
characters basically fight forever
both of these combatants condition out
an insane amount of damage but they can
also each absorb an insane amount of
damage due to their durability and
healing factors I don't really believe
the Hulk actually has any weakness at
Doom's they can adapt to an exploit in
his battle with Superman doomsday was
eventually able to win because Superman
suffered fatigue and became weaker but
as the hole continues to take damage
he becomes angrier and therefore becomes
stronger since the Hulk strength knows
no upper limit I think that eventually
he'll be able to deal enough damage to
overcome Doomsday's durability and
healing so in an individual battle I
think the Hulk would win of course
doomsday will simply continue to come
back to life each time being harder to
kill than the previous time and so quite
literally I think we see these two
fighting forever
with the Hulk repeatedly killing
doomsday after a lengthy battle and
doomsday can
resurrecting himself to fight yet again
but with that being said guys I know
it's not the best answer ever I know you
guys want me to pick a winner here but I
don't really see one I mean you're
talking about a being they can just get
stronger forever versus a guy who can
just constantly resurrect himself
forever so I don't know like amore
immortality versus infinite strength I
don't really know I'm not really sure
here I mean it's kind of a tough one
but let me know you guys think down in
the comments section and yeah thanks for
being patrons and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]